the new film the bubble is available uh
in theaters coming up this friday and on
netflix on april 1st and this is a film
about a movie taking place in a bubble
in a pandemic we're not we don't know
what exactly has caused the pandemic
exactly we keep it vague understood
otherworldly but i guess we can kind of
guess you know
what uh what we might be talking about
but anyway uh it's a film uh about a
film being made called cliff beat six
that appears to be some sort of major
tentpole film that's being made it's a
flying dinosaur film okay
the cast fred armisen's the director
david duchovny pedro pascal leslie mann
iris apatow your daughter one of your
two daughters who acts and so the
genesis of this film was obviously what
was the nba bubble
it really was that's what it was i was i
was taking these long walks on the beach
with my friend to just stay sane yes
every day and one day i'm like we should
try to think of movies let's just think
of movies every day yes well and not
that we thought we would make them
because everything was shut down right
and i said there's something funny about
this nba bubble like everyone's like
stuck together it must be pretty intense
and there was uh the athlete who went to
a funeral and then he came back and got
chicken wings at the strip club yes that
was lou williams i believe that's the
famed lou williams in atlanta right he
as one does when they go to a wedding
right so i would say lou williams is the
reason why we made this movie because
that's really what it is about it's just
people cracking and testing the rules
and and having a hard time continuing to
do their job in the pandemic so i
thought maybe that's a play you could do
what if you did a play and everyone in
the play was seven feet tall
and then i started hearing about you
know jurassic was was shooting and they
were dealing with mission impossible
and i thought well people like beating
up on actors in movies you can always
make fun of them a little bit more so
it's switched to that that's the bubble
again uh judd apatow here on the rich
eisen show in theaters uh this friday
and on netflix i don't think it's in
theaters i think it's just netflix
except there are some select theaters
i've been told there are select these
are select theories but i think on april
1st april 1st not the week before like
in
in in los angeles the there's a theater
in the pacific palisades okay i think
the paris and new york those are select
those
in your underwear at home okay good but
i mean if we're all some of some people
are still in their bubbles a little bit
too yeah mentally some people may never
leave their body very good and so the
nba you know the nba bubble was a wild
construct because it's it's in a theme
park right yes it's where normally
people are coming from all around the
world and just hanging out and their
passport to fun and now all these nba
players are yeah are setting things up
and the one and the rooms are not as
luxurious as most of those
guys are used to correct we didn't hear
a lot about that but there were
certainly people saying the tub isn't
big enough they're not used to seeing
the the donald duck themed wallpaper
in their hotel rooms right or taking a
monorail to work and wasn't there one
guy who started videotaping all of it
and then they shut him down
like yo don't talk about what's
happening it's like fight club we don't
talk about the bubble but the one aspect
of of the bubble that you know we've
been talking about on the show that uh
still lingers today is the nba coaches
use the bubble to get rid of wearing
suits
they don't wear the clothes that's over
the suits are over and it's never coming
back we ask every nba coach that comes
on here like what what they were like we
weren't bringing our suits there was no
dry cleaning no shot now they dress like
they're going to the gym
and now you don't know who the coach is
you have no zero it could be just like i
walk to go get a soda you think i'm the
coach
you should try calling a play at uh
crypto whatever that's what they call it
now i don't like that they call it
crypto it's like beanie bay baby arena
you know it's like a pet rock arena you
don't want to be part of a fad as the
name of your arena
[Laughter]
the cabbage patch arena jack
exactly let's get a little more solid
with your business before you start
naming the arena the funny thing is
around here judd apatow here on the rich
island show was the number of la sports
fans that looked about the renaming of
the arena as if it was like a lost era
an era missing
staples
you have no idea because you get used to
anything whatever it is like you know
shea stadium what was shea
well that was but what was the word shea
i think it was named after like some guy
who you know probably was tight with
robert moses back in the day splitting
up the city you know or whatever i still
say
right i can't help it but i don't even
know what it means but it's just it's in
my heart so you're you're from queens
originally i was born in fleshing flush
yeah so in the in the shadow of shea
state exactly and i made a 30 for 30
about yeah yeah so what did you what did
you learn from that 30 30 did you learn
anything new at all anything new about
doc and daryl at all or what i think
that we thought that we would talk about
a common experience two very young
men who were
thought to be the saviors
and that's a lot of pressure and they
were the saviors they pulled it off but
then really had a terrible struggle
afterwards with their sobriety right and
we wanted to get them together because i
i thought as a fan i've never seen them
talk about it
and that really was the intention for
them to share the experience of what
that was okay and you so you met your
heroes clearly well i mean i went to
those games when i was a kid
uh
in 84 85 that was my you know junior and
senior year of high school then i went
to college
in 86 i was at usc i didn't have time to
follow baseball because it was my first
year of college so the only year i
didn't follow was the year that they won
are you kidding me exactly
are you serious yeah i mean and i was so
wounded from the previous two years
because they would always just miss the
playoffs by like a game and a half and
it was always close that it
i i said i don't know if i want to be in
this much pain in my life following
something this closely i'm gonna let it
go next year yes and then they won okay
yeah 86 was my first year of college i'm
a yankee fan so i didn't know met red
sox i just i wanted them both to lose
like somehow the earth would open up and
swallow both teams
you know i just didn't know which to do
so you you growing up in the new york
city metropolitan area you must have
been around a bunch of guys that you
grew up with who always claimed to have
been part of something that they really
had no business claiming right you've
probably been around those people like
that that guy over there mike del tufo
is our sound
audio executives he likes to be called
he claims to you claim to have started
the k corner right now
okay what is that i didn't start the k
corner i knew the guys that did it
because i was i used to go to games in
85 86 yeah it was my when i left the
yankees for a few years okay that was a
yankees fan you were in the new york
times
in the new york times because a reporter
was there on opening day
the day that carter hit the home run to
win the game yes and it was the first
game of the season and i was there the
guys had left we had met the guys the
year before so we became friends with
them because we would sit they left the
corner left
the whole group they had
and the guys are like who does the k
corner and people pointed down us and
then
but are they your k's are you bringing
kate did you bring the caves did they
leave the cage no the cave we had
everything was there it just stayed
there day and night
in a backwards
my friend myself and my friend john were
interviewed there you go so
theoretically
we could say but there's an actual guy
that you're the team you're like the uh
sean connery of case you're not the
[Laughter]
the first year of uh so i couldn't go to
see them i think they played the cubs
yeah yeah you got 18 strikeouts we went
ever we went all the time it was it was
one of the most exciting things i've
ever seen it was
every throw yeah was like the last pitch
of a game and i i it really was bizarre
that the place exploded on every throw
i've never seen anything yeah you
clapping i once went to again i think it
was against the brewers rob dear if that
name rings a bell i think he i think he
struck out five times but i don't think
he laid a wood on the ball
that night and it really was a circus
when when when goodies started
basically i'm just telling you this
story and introducing you to mike tell
two photos say your 30 for 30 wasn't
completely comprehensive if it did not
have
there was a lot of that's why they have
that other amazing documentary the uh
the one that camel did yeah
most of the time and it's funny because
i hosted the director's guild awards the
other night and speaking of suffering
spike lee is in the crowd okay and i'm
hosting
and i'll tell you the joke i did to
spike lee sure i had to work up the
nerve
to say i just said spike lee has done so
many incredible things in his career
he's a brilliant director documentarian
commercial director actor and what's
most incredible is he is also a knicks
fan and he did all of that while
depressed
and did you did you look to see if he
was laughing and then i said uh it is
very very uh difficult to direct when
james dolan owns your team
and the last joke was i said
spike you being at all the games
has not helped
that's
by the way true
all good jokes have a german truth in it
i think he's the greatest it was a great
night he won the lifetime achievement
award at the director's guild awards
gave like very very moving speech but it
was a it was incredible to meet him
because i'm a new yorker and it was the
first time i met him i also saw your
joke about succession that was really
funny yes where you said that
all the all the directing
every every nomination for best director
of the tv show was succession yes all
five yes and i said so you're saying
that the worst episode of succession is
better than every single thing on
television like even the yellowstone
episode with a shot of the diner is not
as good as the fifth episode best
episode of succession
again you're not wrong
that's what it is saying exactly funny
joe dapatow here on the rich eisen show
the bubble is available on netflix on
friday april 1st this book i'm holding
up right here uh sicker in the head more
conversations about life and comedy
available on march 29th wherever you get
your books what's this book about
pre-order it if you like that kind of
thing why not it's um
i like to interview comedians i started
doing it when i was 15. i interviewed
like steve allen and seinfeld and howard
stern when i was in high school in the
80s how did you get in touch with him i
would just lie to people and just say it
was a real radio station but it was a
high school radio station and the signal
didn't get out of the parking lot look
at that photograph yeah there's me and
jerry
uh
and look at his look at on the left
there at his bookshelf
that's his that's his apartment that is
a guy who is writing jokes that's why
he's the king yeah he is built to create
his comedy he doesn't have time to fill
that book so you went to his apartment
and interviewed him there yeah and uh
and so then i put out uh a book of those
interviews and some new ones with people
like john stewart and chris rock called
sick in the head and we give all the
money away to charity to this uh place
called 826 which provides free tutoring
to kids
uh and so for the new book i did a lot
of it during the pandemic when i knew
people were home so i was able to get
people like letterman and whoopi
goldberg and manuel miranda and sasha
baron cohen because everyone was home
yes that's why i started calling people
like i know you're home yeah you could
talk to me now can't be you can't avoid
your call yeah right and that's there in
the book sicker in the head yeah we'll
be doing some fun events there's a night
at the 92y
where i'll be there and uh you know we
have a uh some stuff in la so if you go
to my website juddapatow.com you can see
me live talking to comedians about the
book fantastic and again that's
available where all books are sold on
march 29th but you can pre-order right
now um we have a segment sir called
celebrity true or false okay there are
stories from your past that we want to
know if they are true or false to make
sure that the internet is accurate if
that's okay that's all we want i
appreciate that hit it we actually have
so we're so close to the internet being
accurate that this may this is going to
lock it up exactly this will be this
will lock it up and we you know we even
have some production value to it go
ahead and roll it go ahead
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
that's it that's our production value i
like it what do you think i mean as a
producer director what do you think
that's like the kind of cut and paste
graphics you just download from some
site that's what we've got
that's what we've got all the budgets
you're looking at the whole business
this is pretty nice
thank you you you've scored we have no
other situation the crazy thing is we we
find stuff here every day that we've had
no idea what's here and half of it's
broken we have no idea how it got broken
okay uh first up uh judd apatow
celebrity true or false true or false
you dropped out of college in your
second year and wound up moving into an
apartment with adam sandler is that a
true story that is that is a true story
how did you
move in with adam sandler how did that
work well adam at the time was living
with alan covert
well he's in all of his movies and alan
you know from grandma's boy and uh he
produces adam's movies hilarious and
they were living together
and at some point i'm not sure covert
was covering the the rent i think it's
how i got in there
i think it was some sort of transition
of uh alan had a different situation and
then adam needed a new roommate
i paid 425 from my room he paid 4.75
because his room had the bathroom in the
room in our little
uh
terrible apartment in north hollywood
okay and so that was like our
early years as comedians trying to catch
a break then he got saturday night live
and left me alone in the apartment with
alan covert no i was alone in the
apartment but i i realized this the
other day when he left to snl he didn't
bring his clothes
or his id he just left
it just disappeared like you know
someone who disappeared forever i
literally have his driver's license
1991.
he just said screw it i'm gone i'm there
i got the car something else was
happening
all right second one um you
interviewed gary shandling as part of
what you just mentioned as a teenager
for your radio station yes and that's
how you wound up getting hired to write
jokes
for shandling when he hosted the 91
grammy awards is that well that is false
okay i interviewed him
uh
when i was a kid on the phone he was in
vegas but he had just hosted the tonight
show for the first time which was a big
deal and he was hilarious on the phone
then i didn't you know i i wouldn't
follow up
afterwards because i was a child i was
16 years old yes you can't really follow
up and go hey do you want to be my
friend okay but later uh in life i was
doing stand-up and he was doing stand-up
and he was about to host the grammys and
he needed someone to help him write
jokes and that was my first
really significant job in show business
and then i went to new york and
sinatra's on the show bob dylan
bono it was it was crazy you know
because i had never been around sinatra
was performing in the 91 grammys you got
the lifetime achievement award that year
and bono gave it to him and nicholson
gave an award to bob dylan
it was it was a very very cool oh my god
do you remember any of the jokes that
you wrote for shandling i always
remember one joke
which is there was a country western guy
with really long sideburns yeah and gary
said i've never seen sideburns like that
before and i'm a trekkie
well i i know um you know your
documentary that that that was on hbo
about his life through his diaries is
one of the most amazing
things i've ever seen thank you it was
so beautiful
and um it's not hbo max and and everyone
should see it honestly because it it it
just
it it it just reveals a human being that
made so many people laugh that had you
know his own demons and his way that he
always seemed to have a positive outlook
despite that certainly what he wrote
about and i
was fortunate enough to be introduced to
him about a couple of years before his
passing
through a mutual friend and
through that he invited me to lunch and
he sat down and when we sat there he'd
already watched a couple of episodes of
this show and gave me tips about
moving the desk closer to the guest
chair i'm still pretty far away i know
that's the coven thing i think it would
have but it used to be closer it used to
be much closer like literally he told me
that you should be touching knees with
your guest like and and
and then the long emails he would send
with just thoughts and notes it was
unbelie and we had just kind of met yeah
he was very giving that way like i would
like a funny story as i always would
have him at the table reads so before we
shoot a movie we would read it out loud
we get all the actors and we would
invite a lot of friends and writers to
tell us if the movie was working so i
had him at the table read for
the 40 year old virgin
and then the debate afterwards with a
bunch of people adam mckay was there we
were debating
does the 40-year-old virgin masturbate
right
like wouldn't that be a part of this
like can you ignore that concept yes of
self-pleasure in a movie like this and
gary takes a pause and he goes what if
you had a sequence
where you just show him prepare to
masturbate and he puts on his favorite
robe and brushes his hair
and
it's in the movie and it's hysterical he
would do things like that all the time
and that's how that scene got in the
film yeah
fantastic do you have a good uh a go-to
story that you can share about the the
larry sanders show when you were on that
uh about that show i mean everything was
a was a story at the larry sanders show
because you know it's a talk it's it's
behind the scenes of a talk show
it's also an hbo if people want to see
it it's it it truly is in the
conversation of the greatest television
show of all time yeah it's end of story
very funny and the bubba in a way is
like a grand child
to it because it's making fun of the
behind the scenes of people in a bubble
trying to make a flying dinosaur action
movie with terrific cameos and a great
cast and everything yeah so it's
connected but it was just always intense
over there because riptorn was one of
the stars oh my god and riptorn is a was
a genius but very like gruff and
maybe he was drinking certain days like
he was emotionally uh challenging but it
was always worth it because he was the
best ever
and uh one day we're shooting and i'm
directing i've never directed before and
he just turns to the cinematographer
he's like i see what you're doing
i see what you're doing you're shooting
my ear
you're shooting my ear you gave me these
the caesar shots to everyone else but
you're shooting my ear and it didn't
really make sense because the guy was
like right in front of him like
the angle and the guy's like what are
you talking about rip he's like i know
the angles i shoot skeet
and he really like just like goes off
about this
and then later in the day i see him walk
over this cinematographer peter smokeler
who did like spinal tap this amazing
cinematographer yeah and he says you
know this morning i woke up and i was
watching my car like by my house and i
was walking i hit my head on a piece of
wood hanging from my house i'm not mad
at you i'm just mad
because of that because of that
that's the kind of that's how it would
usually roll in a very strange way but
the scene would always be remarkable and
he was like a big oh my god puppy as
artie i mean it's unbeliev one of my
favorite lines because i'm from staten
island by the way great movie the king
of staten island i grew up with every
single person in that film it was as
authentic as it gets
um that just i remember when uh
larry was complaining about the guest
list and it wasn't very up to snuff and
yes dawn tonight we've got
uh staten island streetwise troubadours
the wu-tang clan
well what's funny is gary didn't really
know music that well
i hired my friend julianna roberts like
help book music acts but gary didn't
really know
almost anybody in music so we would book
the people that we just wanted to meet
yes
would the wu tang clan show up here
yeah you know
los lobos is on the show like we would
just i remember we got warren zivan to
do the show yeah and sure we would just
keep introducing people to gary i love
it a couple more here with uh judd
apatow celebrity true or false um
lebron was cast in trainwreck because he
was one of the only players and sports
figures that amy schumer who was writing
it had ever heard of is that true i
think when you write a movie and you
have a joke such as
you know
bill hader is someone who does
operations on people's knees he's a knee
specialist
and
his friend we want his best friend to be
a giant athlete like the most successful
athlete you could think of so amy in
writing would just write
who's the most famous successful person
so in your script you always write that
name and then at the end of the day
you know you get uh i don't know glenn
gondrzek
guys
guys can i do an old reference by the
way that's a golf clap for jeff you
think i'd pull out something like that
from the 70s anyway
so you don't get the person that you
intended to get yes correct and and so
uh bill said well you know he hosted
saturday night live and he's a great guy
and he's really funny
maybe he would do it and and then bill
and i went out to lunch with him
after uh
watching him in a game the night before
and the thing i always remember about
the lunch first of all he got the joke
instantly and he was hysterical like
it's funny because he's really funny and
he understood with the nuance of what
that was
but
he's eating in the restaurant and all
the different lakers keep walking over
uh no it was pre-lakers yeah sure yeah
yeah before that all his teammates keep
walking over and they're all exhausted
from the night before like they look
annihilated at noon the next day
like they looked like they'd been
through something terrible all of them
and they're all like hey how you doing
i'm okay how are you doing and they like
people don't realize what it takes out
of them yes am i right about this it
seems if it was the mo if it was in
miami it could have been a late night
that night it did not make that sense
it looks like true exhaustion okay and i
was like
in my job i'm never that tired
i'm not recovering like that so i i was
impressed that the at the work ethic so
it could be that line from airplane
kareem you tell your dad to drag walton
into linear of the court exactly
walton and lanier's assets
lebron right up there with kareem and
airplane in terms of solid uh but he got
to get he got the idea and he was great
and
he was tremendous in that yeah so was
john cena he was hilarious in that movie
john cena was so funny and also john
cena i i
i can't say i was following wrestling
yeah at the time yes so because you know
i was more of a bruno st martino guy
nice um that's the glenn gonzaga
well he was more successful than that
that's right but um
but but uh cena came in and i didn't i i
someone just showed me a tape like hey
maybe a wrestler could play this part
because we just wanted her to have a
very muscular boyfriend
and i'm like that guy's hilarious and
they're like
yeah he's like the champion i'm like oh
i i literally didn't know who he was
which is
it says bad things about me i should be
following wrestling
and and the nicest funniest guy just so
so game to to go for it came in with
tons of ideas and he's also he does a
funny cameo in the bubble okay very good
the bubble again uh in theaters on april
1st uh and the last one i i know this is
true but it's just a way for you to
please tell the story that steve carell
insisted on having his chest literally
waxed it literally that's real hair what
you're looking at like that's not like
the crop guys made funny hair on the uh
literally his hair that's the hair they
ripped off and we would just put it
there and that is the
that still is the actual reaction
to the pain
of doing and so we had five cameras set
up because you this is one take like you
can you could only do it once you can
only
glue the hair back on and do it and it
was steve's idea he's like i think it'd
be funny yeah now the thing i realized
later yes was he claimed at the time
that he had never waxed before
but now i realize that he had
because he he's a wax he's manscaped
he's landscaped and well you've done you
know anchorman we've done other films
with him but but he really pitches like
i think this would be funny i imagine it
would be funny it would hurt a lot like
no he'd done it
it was all a lie and the woman who who
waxes him
came in and we needed an actress who
also knew how to wax like a professional
actress slash
waxer that's that's quite a switch so i
think the woman maybe did it once or
twice and got fired acting
the number one rule when you wax is you
don't put the wax over the nipple
because you could just rip someone's
nipple off and she did there's like a
shot and we realized later that she lied
that she knew how to wax just to get
apart so that might be why it hurt so
much or maybe it wouldn't have hurt if
she knew how to do it as someone who has
told some fibs in his past you had to
respect her for you know just wanting
the role gotta fake the resume yeah you
gotta if there's anything i can say to
the kids out there
take the resume get the job then prove
you can do it fake it till you make it
oh my god figure it out later and uh
kelly clarkson was just an ad-lib that
was just well you know seth rogen you
know i knew that i wanted him to curse
at her okay because as a kid i always
went to action park
oh my gosh
and so actually park as everyone knows
has these like cement
tracks and you ride these scooters down
them and everyone wiped out on their
arms
and with their all their skin of their
arm would get ripped off and then you
would go to the nurse and the nurse
would spray this like pink antiseptic
antibacterial something on it and every
guy in new york am i allowed to curse
here go for it would
she they would be like
they wouldn't know it would hurt and
then she would spray and they would be
like
you know
but it was like a line of people and it
could be like a nice woman that would
curse out they all cursed out the nurse
and so i told uh
steve that story and i said just every
time act like you're not going to curse
at her and then curse
and then i asked seth can you write out
a list of curses
which he wrote and then i said can you
get a couple of clean curses yes so if i
ever have to air this on abc and then
and then seth wrote kelly clarkson
kelly
oh
have you ever run into her i just did it
last week we're bonded over this joke
oh my gosh fantastic and we'd even touch
on literally two-thirds of what you've
got going on sicker in the head judd
apatow a book where you can pre-order
right now it comes out next week on the
29th and then on the first
of april the bubble i didn't even
mention keegan michael keys in this
movie and he is one of the funniest guys
i have ever met yeah he's been in this i
mean he's been incredible what a heck of
a cast brett arminson fred armisen too
david duchovny is he is he one of your
basketball friends from i used to play
basketball from the famed gary shandling
games yeah and he but he played
like more seriously at college i believe
okay i don't know
did he blame is is that a lie
that'll be for his celebrity true father
but he actually knew how to play okay
but i was mainly covering you know like
weaker people like alan's white bell
bell from he was a great writer yeah
saturday night live legend and he
followed me once and dislocated my
shoulder oh god and then that was the
end of my best that's it that's the end
of it great to see you judd apatow this
was so much fun thank you for coming in
again sticker in the head where all
books are sold and then the bubble check
it out on netflix on april 1st hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here